she was feeling awful she was feeling
very drained very tired very lethargic
very feverish and she just said my body
doesn't feel like it's running right I
feel like I'm dying dialed 999 and they
told her before to five hours for an
ambulance to come to her even though a a
position or her illness was life
critical could have been life critical
Darren Street's daughter has Type 1
diabetes she's collapsed before and was
afraid it could happen again she was
scared she was crying she said I feel
like I'm dying and at that point she's
25 year old young lady but what could we
do is literally get her in the car and
you know sort of throw it to the a e and
say please deal with our daughter she
was admitted into resource within five
minutes and given immediate care that
was on Tuesday the day before ambulance
workers went out on strike many trusts
had already warned of severe pressure
even ahead of the industrial action in
Kent Medway NHS trust became the latest
to declare a critical incident due to a
spike in demand following the strikes
amid warnings the Health Service is
facing a very difficult Christmas we're
in for a challenging time over the next
couple of days because what we do know
is after this kind of strike action or
after something like a bank holiday in
the NHS we know that there is a lot of
pent-up demands
nursing leaders have warned there's no
slack in the system the number of
patients in hospital with flu has
skyrocketed with a surge in patients
needing critical care and strap a is
driving record demand for services five
more children have died in the last week
outside hospitals ambulance delays have
reached a new high
almost a quarter of ambulance patients
in England waited more than an hour to
be handed to a e teams last week that
compares to just one in 20 in the same
week two years ago the issue remains a
shortage of beds around 95 percent of
hospital beds are full
with the whole system under strain NHS
bosses are urging the government and
unions to try to avert further strike
action after Christmas this winter is
going to be incredibly tough there's
nothing we can do about that but the
industrial action adds to what is
already a challenging situation
[Applause]
[Music]
seems like
like its position that it won't
negotiate overpay and unions responding
by announcing more strike dates next
month Becky Johnson Sky News